Hey guys,
What is more important to you - this
temporary world that is passing away?
Or God?
I want you to answer this question
honestly while I explain the following five
things that all Christian men should stop doing.
Let's start with number one.
Stop pursuing the wrong things.
You could pursue a lot of things in life
... money, relationships, power... but
only one pursuit brings satisfaction on earth
because only one pursuit matters for eternity:
becoming a true man of God.
I wrote that on the back cover
of my new book called Bold Pursuit, a 90-day
devotional for men seeking the heart of God.
I believe one of the worst things a man can do is
to waste his God-given life to pursue in his head
the big things, the small things, according
to his three-pound brain because he thinks he
knows better than God to pursue that and to miss
out on what God has actually planned for him.
And if you think that you know better
than God with your small brain then
it's extremely sad because you're missing
out on real purpose and fulfillment and
peace and God's blessing because if
you walk in your own way and not in
God's way - within His will - then God's
blessing is not going to be on your life.
[Proverbs 3:5-6]
This is why so many men are complaining.
And they say things like, I don't understand
why God is not helping me in this and
maybe it's because you are trying to
force doors open that were never meant
to be opened because that's your will.
You're not following God's will.
You're not going through the door that
He has actually planned for you and keeping
open for you that you need to go through.
You see, as a reborn Christian,
you need to abide in Christ.
And then you will produce the right fruit.
[John 15:4]
You see, that is what it means to be a
true child of God and if you are a true
son of God then you don't just think that
God is some part of your life now and then.
When you feel like it.
He is your life now
because He made you a new creation.
He is the one that directs your paths and you
follow Him with your whole heart and soul.
Do you do that?
[Galatians 2:20]
Are you a true son of the almighty living God?
You know, sometimes we forget who God is.
We don't have enough respect for Him.
We just take Him for granted.
Oh my relationship with God and you
kind of bring Him down to your level.
He is God.
Do you understand that?
In the Old Testament, only the high priest was
allowed to enter the holy of holies only once
a year but now after Jesus came and died on a
cross, and rose from the grave ... now when when
we accept Him because of grace, God saves us.
He declares us as righteous and that is why we
can all enter the holy of holies because that
is now, you know, there's no temple anymore.
Because our bodies are the temple of God.
And we can approach His throne with confidence,
but with a lot of respect because
He is still God and He is holy.
When you live that way, when you put God first in
everything... everything that you do ... suddenly
everything else falls into place.
Everything you do is blessed,
because you put God first and that is
the requirement for all His promises.
And then when you start to do that -
when you live this life of complete
surrender - then you start to realize,
man, now you have everything you need.
You have fulfillment, you have purpose,
and you have peace that surpasses all
understanding.
Jesus said:
[Matthew 16:24]
That is the life of complete surrender and
the only life where you will find true peace
that surpasses all understanding even when
you're going through trials and tribulations
because you understand.
Because you abide in God.
Him in you, you in Him.
You can see the bigger picture of life.
Everything starts to make sense.
And you move forward and you can
see how God is just blessing you and you get the
power to overcome any kind of obstacle that this
life throws at you because now you're not tackling
these things alone anymore with only your limited
power mind capability ... three pound small brain.
A lot of people think they know better than God
but now you have the Holy Spirit in you.
The power of God.
He is leading you and helping you.
He is in your corner fighting for you.
Let's move on to the next one.
Stop thinking you are always right.
That kind of arrogant prideful hard attitude
does not fit in with the new Christian lifestyle.
That might have been part of your old lifestyle -
the person you used to be - but remember you are
a new creation in Christ and now you are humble.
You live according to the Spirit, not according
to that old sinful flesh that's full
of the ego and the "I" "me-me-me".
Sinful flesh.
There's a change because you love God.
You also love other people because
that's the Holy Spirit in you.
You know you've received that
unconditional sacrificial love from God.
Agape love.
And God's
love for other people flows through you.
So then you start to understand... man,
you need to be the light of the world.
You need to be a sweet smelling aroma so
it's more important to win the person than it is
to win the argument in the flesh, full of pride,
because you just want to win the argument.
You keep on fighting and you want to be right.
Forgetting that you need to win
the soul of that person for Christ.
So you might win the argument
but you will lose the person.
[Proverbs 16:18]
One of the ugliest things that you can
see is a self-professed Christian man
arguing - quarreling with an unbeliever
for example - about religious things.
But he's doing it through
the flesh, full of pride.
Full of ego.
Because he wants to win
that conversation, that argument.
And he's not sharing the Gospel,
taking the lead of the Holy Spirit
in truth and in love, being humble.
[Proverbs 11:2]
[Proverbs 16:5]
You know, there's a lot of people who just want
to keep on fighting, you know. They're like,
I'm right, I'm right, I'm right.
And they will keep on fighting,
because it is so important for them to be right.
You know that is from the sinful flesh and even
when they are right and the other
person says, okay, you're right,
they will... they will keep on going.
They will say things like, yeah, you see?
You see?
I told you.
Even when things happen at the end
they're like, I told you this happened.
You don't need to do that.
That kind of attitude is not
part of the new life in Christ.
Examine yourself - ask yourself
- and be brutally honest.
Do you think you're always right?
Will you argue with them until they see things the
way you do because you think you're always right?
If you are, then you need to stop living in sin,
because that is sin.
You are quenching the Holy Spirit
and you need to obey God, not just in the way in
what you say but also in the way you say things.
[Romans 12:16]
Did you read that?
It says sometimes be wise in your own sight.
No, it didn't say that.
Did it say 50 percent of the time
be wise in your own sight?
No.
Did it say one percent of the
time be wise in your own sight?
No.
It says never never never
be wise in your own sight.
No one likes people who think that they are always
right because they reek of puffed up egos and it
pushes people away from the Gospel.
God actually says in Philippians 2:3:
[Philippians 2:3-4]
If you truly love God, with everything that
is in you, you will also love other people
and you will care about them.
You will try to understand
things from their perspectives.
You know, the biggest challenge
for every reborn believer Christian is not
other people or the things in this world.
It is the self-life.
That is why Jesus said
if you want to follow Him, you need to deny
yourself, pick up your cross, and follow Him.
Pick up your cross - that means you
need to crucify yourself with Jesus.
That old sinful flesh.
Let's move on to the next one.
Stop making excuses for your fleshly nature.
Christian men do that a lot more than they think.
For example, some make excuses or
lie like the rest of the world.
They get to work late and then they
say things like, sorry, I'm late.
It was traffic.
Well, they actually
have a cup of coffee takeaway in their hand,
meaning they took 10 to 20 minutes to buy that
coffee and also knowing that everyone else
in a meeting had to sit in the same traffic.
So it's just an excuse.
That's not the reason why you're late.
The reason you're late is because you
took some time to get that coffee and
also because you didn't plan ahead.
You didn't wake up early enough.
Another excuse I sometimes hear at
church - at Bible study - is this:
I could not spend time studying the
Bible this week because I was too busy.
Because I was too busy?
That's an excuse.
An excuse to try and rationalize
your sinful behavior.
You make time for that which is a priority to you.
So if you didn't make time for God that week, it
means you took other things and put it above God.
You made those things a priority while God
says you have to make Him your priority.
Do you know most men who say that they are
Christians have never read the entire Bible?
They don't really make God their priority.
And you know, I've heard this saying a
lot, you know, in the Christian Community.
God doesn't call the equipped.
he equips the called, but what they
don't understand is that is what the Bible does.
The Bible equips us so some of them sit back and
they want God to do everything.
It is your responsibility to
grow with Christ, to read scripture.
To take time, to spend time with God.
[2 Timothy 3:16-17]
Now listen to this.
The Bible equips you for every good work but how
will you be equipped if you don't read the Bible?
You can't.
And as men,
you know we are normally
straight with one another.
So let me be straight with you.
Stop the excuses.
Spend time with God.
Read your Bible.
And then, stop to be just a hearer
of the Word and start to be a doer.
Because Jesus says if you love
me you will obey my commandments.
[2 Timothy 2:15]
Nowhere does it say that only preachers or
pastors need to study the Word of God and know it.
It doesn't say that at all.
They cannot live your Christian life for you.
You have your own relationship with God.
When you die, you alone will
stand in front of God.
Not your pastor, not your husband,
not your wife, not your children.
No one in your family.
None of your friends.
You alone.
You will have to give account.
So let us stop making the same kind of excuses,
like the rest of the sinful world.
We are called to be set apart.
We are ambassadors of Christ.
We are in the world but we
are not part of the world.
Let's go on to the next one.
Stop saying vulgar words like
the rest of the sinful world.
You know, I'm shocked when I'm ... when I hear
someone who said that they're a Christian and
I just hear them speak these vulgar words.
I feel the Holy Spirit in me, ah that pain,
and they continue the conversation
as if everything is fine.
And they even use God's name in
vain, having no respect for God.
God's name.
Would Jesus do that?
Would Jesus speak vulgar words?
And you know I'm telling you these
things because I actually really care about you,
because a lot of people out there are sleeping.
They think that they're Christians but
they're living like the rest of mankind.
So they're lukewarm or
they're not Christian at all.
They think they are but they'll get
a big surprise at the day of judgment
and I don't want that to happen to you.
I don't want you to be self-deceived.
[Ephesians 4:29-30]
You see, true faith doesn't
mean that you just continue to
live in sin and don't care about it at all.
Paul wrote about this in detail, in Romans.
The rest of the New Testament
talks about it as well.
Faith without works is dead.
In James, faith is not like a
jacket that you just sometimes put on
and take off when you feel like it.
You have been changed.
God Himself changed you.
He did a work of regeneration and gave you
the Holy Spirit, which means you have a whole
new spiritual nature within you.
And then if you do sin the Holy
Spirit will convict you.
You'll feel bad about it
until you can't take it anymore.
And you'll say God, please forgive me.
I'm sorry.
I don't want to
live the way I used to live anymore.
If that regeneration did not happen,
if you didn't truly repent and accept Jesus
Christ as Lord and Savior, it's not a thing
that you grow up as in a tradition.
Oh, I'm just now Christian.
No, you need to be a reborn Christian.
John 3, Jesus talks about in detail.
If you didn't truly accept Jesus Christ as
Lord and Savior, and He came to change you,
give you the Holy Spirit, then
you are not a Christian even if
you grew up in a Christian home or go
to church or read your Bible sometimes.
[2 Corinthians 5:17]
People will be judged by every
careless word they speak.
So with your new lifestyle it is impossible to
say the same kind of things that you used to say.
Vulgar words - bad words - and even
breaking people down in the flesh.
You are supposed to be the light of the world.
[Matthew 12:35-37]
If you truly are a Christian
man, why would you want to tell
dirty jokes and speak vulgar words?
I ask you again, would Jesus do that?
[Ephesians 5:4]
How have you been living your life recently?
I'm just talking about vulgar words
but there might be other sin as well.
How have you been living your life recently?
Be brutally honest with yourself.
This is important because if you would
die today, how will God judge you?
The reason you're still alive means that
God is still giving you a time of grace
and every time you take that breath
it is a breath closer to your death.
Then that time of grace is
done and then it is judgment.
And then you will stand in
front of God who is love, yes.
But He is also righteous, because He is holy.
Let's move on to the next one.
Stop being lazy.
Spiritual laziness is sin.
Paul tells us in Romans 12:11:
[Romans 12:11]
This is a lot more important than you think.
And I believe that we should preach
about this a lot more in church.
Let me read you something very interesting.
From my book, Bold Pursuit, a 90-day devotional
for men seeking the heart of God.
Day 48: Someone once said:
The Greek word translated as laziness in the
Bible is akedia, which means the absence of care.
This kind of laziness isn't caused
by a lack of physical energy.
It is a sinful condition of the heart that causes
people not to care about anyone or anything.
The consequences of laziness are dramatic.
[Proverbs 21:25]
Spiritual laziness is especially dangerous.
That's when we don't care enough to read our Bible
or go to church or pray to our heavenly Father.
The Bible has an interesting
command to those who are lazy.
[Proverbs 6:6-8]
In its own way, the ant understands
that work is an investment.
It diligently gathers food while
its available and stores it away.
The ant understands that a time of plenty is
the perfect time to prepare for a time of need.
So it puts in the work to prepare for winter
when provisions are scarce and life is harder.
That's the reality God wants us to understand.
Spiritual work is an investment.
Making the effort to study Scripture,
go to church and spend time daily in
prayer has immediate benefits of course.
But it also has long-term benefits.
Being grounded in Scripture can help
us resist Satan's temptations as it did for
Jesus during his temptation in the wilderness.
[Matthew 4:1-11]
Surrounding ourselves with a network of
fellow believers can Inspire us to live out
our faith in bold and impactful ways.
That's why Hebrews 10: 24-25 says:
[Hebrews 10:24-25]
Staying in constant communication
with our heavenly Father can help
us recognize His will for our life.
To enjoy these spiritual benefits
we must resist the pull of laziness and stay
disciplined in every area of our spiritual life.
We must stay constantly aware that the
work we do now to understand scripture,
build relationships with fellow believers,
and maintain an open line of communication with
God will pay dividends for the rest of our life.
Now, at the end of each daily devotional I
ask you to dig deep because we need to be
doers of the Word and not just hearers only.
So this is is time to examine yourself and
to be honest.
Dig deep.
Ask yourself the following questions
and answer them truthfully.
Take some time to answer these questions honestly
- truthfully - and if you want to take a look at
my book, I'll add all the information for
you in the video description down below.
Now, if you haven't subscribed yet, please do so.
We have a lot of videos on the channel and
we bring out weekly videos so you might be
interested to watch one of these playlists here.
And before you go, always remember.
Life is short, so please do not
waste yours.
Bye guys.